anybody's ever worked a sales job
there's three types of prospects there's
people that are never gonna buy there's
people that are on the fence and there's
people that are interested in gotta buy
so they're not equal thirds
if your product is good and you're good
at what your job you're good at what
you're doing the people that want to buy
from you will get larger as you get
better and as your product improves so
as your smv increases the pool of people
that will be interested in you
grows larger as it's the lower it is
like you're going to have less people
that are having genuine desire for you
and that are interested so it's not like
33 of girls are interested 33 or not and
33 are fence sitters you want to focus
on that top 33 well that 30 percent 33
can grow to 50. you can go to 60 can
grow to 80
depending on your level of smv so it's
not always just about well i only have a
103 chance like you can
widen that pool and increase your
chances the better you are doing so it's
always better to level yourself up
because your pool just will get larger
yeah and let me just talk about that for
a minute because i had a consult earlier
today with a guy that's a high net worth
individual very successful entrepreneur
he's looking for a wife and fine you
know like you want to get married you
want to have kids cool but he wants to
minimize the risk exposure right and
like the very first thing that i needed
to work on with this guy he needed to
lose weight like straight up very
successful would be a very valuable
target for women especially you know
like a woman with a personality disorder
that could invite some serious chaos
into his lies
and it was like dude if you want to
expand your options like if you want to
have a better experience and expand your
options you're just going to get there
by increasing your smb and i said to my
god you know a scale of one to ten with
ten being the best version one being the
worst where do you put yourself high six
low seven ish sort of thing so imagine
how much less dirt you're gonna have to
dig through to find gold if you're a 10
out of ten you know if you're the best
version of yourself and that's a great
point moth because i mean if you're not
there then you're going to spend way too
much time chasing women way too much
well there's no guarantees in any
relationship you get into
but there is insurance
okay and the best insurance you got is
your smv and her
genuine desire towards you
you know if she has genuine desire
towards you that is the best insurance
you have so when you run into
difficulties which are inevitable she'll
be
wanting to be with you and to make that
work very simple and if she doesn't have
that desire for you if it's not uh if
it's not
maintained and it turns into a
transaction or exchange
your insurance is over with
it's only it's only a matter of time
before
the demise of that thing happens whether
it's you being in it and it's over and
you find yourself a slave to somebody
else's imperatives or whether it's her
moving on to something else you know
well i want to i want to bring something
up and paul you and i have talked about
this in session before where you go with
that jake and i just asked you to hold
that thought just real quick i got guys
waiting in the green room to come on and
i've got one person that's left a
comment on what they want to talk about
turn on your cameras and tell me what it
is in the private shot that you want to
talk about what your question is and
then i'm going to sort through them and
i'll bring you in if it's appropriate so
go ahead jay
so one of the things paul and i worked
on shortly after my divorce was
guys like us are a huge target
huge target yeah and that's the and the
only way to distinguish between you know
who could be kind of potential long-term
material and who is not is that
difference between validation and
transactional sex
and something i've heard ryan stone talk
about a million times is he said the
vast majority of men will never get
validation sex i never don't even
understand it they don't even know what
it feels like no idea and so when you
start to experience that you're like oh
okay this is that really looks like
yeah that's what it has nothing to do
with money it's got nothing to do with
status that they just want to be with
you and you know there's a and to give
you guys a corollary to kind of answer
that guy's question that you had in
session
uh rich
you will run into a lot of women that
want to have kids and something rollo
has said it's like there's a lot of
women that want to have kids but do they
want to have your kids correct because
that's a very different relationship
than i just want to be a mommy no i want
to have your kids is a very different
relationship it's very different because
she's not going to try to hyphenate the
kid's name she's not going to protest
and insist that she that she names the
firstborn son
she's okay with taking on his name she's
okay with him naming you know the son
right like there's a lot of things that
kind of intermingle with all that when
you're going through the vetting process
and you might think that you found gold
but then you know when you start to get
into parenting and
how that relationship's gonna look if
you live together and raise kids
together and it's potentially
problematic guys that are spoiled for
choice that are chasing excellence not
women will let her go to invite a better
candidate into his life than to make
those concessions
and then invite a nightmare right
um let me see what we got here we gonna
okay guys yeah thanks for leaving the uh
private chats here with the questions
you guys want to talk about anything
else before i start pulling in some
people with questions
don't get me started i'll go all day i
know
that's that's a great point jason made
and i've experienced that like for the
first time in the last year was the the
validation is
you know it's like driving a four
cylinder compared to a v8 yeah it like
it blew my mind it it like it it when
someone just absolutely wants to shred
you to pieces on site yeah it's a
different game completely for me the
first time i didn't know what it was it
felt like i was completely sober too i
was like it felt like a drug like i was
having like a
like psychedelic experience or like
ecstasy for the first time you're like
what is this there was this other force
and that for me i think now that's the
addiction that's that's the the rush i
chase whereas before in the beta days
you're chasing the fantasy
it's the only thing that's acceptable
once you've had it right it's like you
know if you drive a fine automobile
you're not gonna go back to your 1982
chevy chevette that you drove when you
were broke as a joke and at you know 19
years old right i saw my car and bought
a pedal bike like i'm not going to buy
like a crappy little nissan or something
to drive around here i'll just i'll just
go on twitter on a bike
i got a guy here
i will tell you this just
the first time i had that happen to me
and you guys are going to laugh your ass
off at this
it actually scared me i was like what is
going on like it was so intense and it
was so like i was like whoa what's going
on like i can remember like if i felt
at one point i felt like my brain got
rewired because i'm like oh this is what
it's supposed to be
this is what it's supposed to be like
bingo
and something sterling cooper had said
one time he said you know i mean
sterling's an adult film star right he
goes you know everybody thinks it's
really cool
like to to do this stuff to get paid to
be with women and he goes i'm telling
you like the the difference between that
and validational sex is massive
like he's like i would much rather you
know be with somebody who really wants
to be with me aside from you know
getting paid getting paid
yeah
you